here's part one of my interview with
Israeli Prime Minister just hours ago
Benjamin
Netanyahu and joining us now is Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu Mr
Prime Minister great to have you back um
we I've known you we've been friends for
decades and I just want to express at
the top of this interview uh my deepest
sympathy uh for all that you and your
fellow countrymen are going through um I
remember you stood strong and steadfast
with America after 9/11 and had a lot of
moral Clarity uh when others did not and
I'm grateful for that and I think it's
now time for America to do the same for
you uh but I am my deepest sympathies
for what you're dealing with well thank
you Sean and and thank the American
people across the board the American
government Congress the Senate the
president everybody uh has been very
very strong for Israel because they
understand that our fight is your fight
and our Victory is your Victory and
there is no substitute for victory we
have to have the forces of civilization
beat these barbarians because otherwise
this barbarism will spread and will
endanger the entire world every American
uh every civilized country would be
under Peril we have to win there is no
substitute for victory total Victory uh
I I I hear you say that it reminds me of
Winston Churchill in World War II what
what what is our aim our aim I could say
in one word Victory then he spoke at
length victory iory against a monstrous
tyranny and this group Hamas is only one
of your enemies and they have in their
very Charter the destruction of your
country uh you actually Ed the phrase if
I could read it to you if you want peace
you have to destroy Hamas um I agree
with you but that's Hamas in the South
Rockets are being fired into your
country from the north out of Lebanon uh
you have the houti rebels uh that have
declared war against you out of Yemen
you have Syria are firing missiles at
you then you then you have the the head
of the snake Iran orchestrating all of
these these proxy conflicts so I I ask
you this question if we're going to
Define what victory looks like does
doesn't that have to be Gaza could no
longer be a launching pad for Rockets
being fired into your country Lebanon
could no longer be a launching area for
Rockets being fired into your country uh
doesn't that mean the network of Terror
tunnels and I've I've been in some of
them
um as you know uh that all those Terror
tunnels have to be destroyed doesn't it
also mean on some level that Iran has to
be dealt with for total
Victory well if you connect the dots you
see that there's an axis of Terror here
against an alliance for peace the access
of Terror is controlled by Iran run by
Iran financed by Iran Iran hisbah in
Lebanon Hamas in Gaza the htis in Yemen
and their other minions
they want to bring the Middle East the
world back to the Dark Ages Early Middle
Ages that's what they are about and on
the other side stands Israel the
moderate Arab states of course the
United States all the forces that want
to see peace prosperity uh for the
Middle East and for the world and that's
the battle that is being waged right now
it's being waged right now most
importantly and most decisively in Kamas
one of the extensions of this axis of
Terror and everybody's waiting to see
who's going to win is Israel going to
win or Hamas going to win but it's not
merely Israel's Victory it's our victory
over the axis because when they see that
we defeated them in one place we'll
defeat them in every place because
that's how power Works they want to see
who's winning we have to win not only
for our sake for the sake of the Middle
East for the sake of our Arab neighbors
you know what for the sake of gazans who
have been held by this dark tyranny that
is brutalized and brought them nothing
but Bloodshed and poverty and misery
that we have to win to protect Israel we
have to win to safeguard the Middle East
we have to win for the sake of the
Civilized world that's the battle we're
fighting and it's being waged right now
there's no substitute for that Victory
it'll affect the other theaters that you
mentioned as well o over 28 communities
in the north uh near the the border with
Lebanon have had to be evacuated there's
always been a concern about a two-front
war um my concern is even larger than
that and that is that you know if
Rockets are being fired out of Syria or
HTI Rebels are firing Rockets into
Israel that becomes an even bigger
conflict but I agree with your general
point you you always said that that
radical islamists view Israel as the
little Satan America as the big Satan
that's a phrase you've used often
they've used it they say America is the
great Satan and we're the small Satan
we're just a small Satan standing in
their way to get it you the great Satan
because they you know what all these
radicals these terrorists these mon
monstrous regimes and organizations they
say there's no difference between Israel
and the United States you are them and
they are you because we represent these
same values of Freedom respect for human
life respect for individual liberty they
have nothing of that they don't care for
their people they don't care for Liberty
they don't care for life they glorify
death they glorify murder remember what
happened here I mean what what happened
here was that Israel was attacked
unprovoked by a sea of terrorists who
stormed into our communities murder and
raped women uh burned children uh I I
met a soldier today an Arab soldier in
the in the Israeli Army who said the
first thing I saw was the corpse of a
woman beheaded they behead women they
they fired
on youngsters celebrating a music
festival they they put them in a
deathbed like in bobar and the Holocaust
and fired machine guns into them mowing
them down they took hostages they took
they took a 10mon old baby hostage what
kind of monsters hold babies hostages
Holocaust Survivors they took hostages
men women children elderly these are
monstrous monstrous terrorists and they
perpetrated the worst hores against the
Jewish people since the Holocaust and if
we let them get away with it this
barbarism will spread you know what the
difference is Sean you know at least the
Nazis and Stalin they wanted to hide
their crimes these people glorify their
crimes they bring GoPro cameras for
their murders to show the entire world
they celebrated so who's going to win
are the good guys going to win or the
bad guys are going to win and of course
we have to make sure that the forces of
good the forces of Peace the forces of
progress and prosperity they win and not
the forces that take us back to the Dark
Ages that's the battle and it'll affect
every single person not only in the
Middle East but well beyond because if
if Israel is imp periled if the Middle
East goes down Europe is next it's like
Isis you know people thought it was a
local thing it wasn't it was a global
thing and it affected Americans it
beheaded Americans if we don't win now
then Europe is next and you're next and
we have to win we have to win there is
no substitute for total Victory you you
you mentioned the atrocities being
chronicled and they had GoPro cameras
the IDF has shown people in the media
and it's been described in great detail
to me and I have an appointment to see
this as well all of these human
atrocities that you speak of are on on
videotape you have some 40 plus minutes
of tape available um I understand and
I've I've watched videos of beheadings
these are not images that one will ever
be able to erase from their mind and you
wouldn't think that such evil exists in
this world but it does um and these
tapes are available for the world to see
you would it be wise perhaps for the IDF
to pixel out faces so that families are
not having to deal with the trauma of of
seeing this uh but let the world see the
the the magnitude of evil that you are
destroying yes they rape women yes they
slaughtered babies and women and
children yes they beheaded babies yes
they burned babies all of which much of
which has been chronicled would it be
worthwhile for the world to fully to to
have the the moral Clarity to understand
the barbarism the Monstrous evil that
we're talking about here because it's
it's on
videotape yes you're quite right uh
there's sensitivity of the families we
we respect that and we try to persuade
them to do exactly what you said and I
think we're getting somewhere we show it
to selective leaders in America and
elsewhere in the world and people you
know people watch these
tapes and they shudder some break out
into tears because the inhumanity the
deliberate
not merely the deliberate murder of
people the deliberate murder mutilation
the ripping off of body parts the
beheadings they are so you know it's
accompanied with such fish Glee the joy
of murder the joy of Terror the joy of
torture it's just absolutely
extraordinary and this is the battle
we're fighting now it's a very difficult
enemy to fight because it's committing a
double War crime not only is it
deliberately targeting civilians our
civilians but it's Del L hiding behind
their civilians because they implant
themselves in schools and hospitals uh
in uh in un facilities in civilian
neighborhoods that's where they put
their rockets that they that's where
they put their command post and they see
immunity there and of course we can't
give them that immunity we try to do
everything in our power to minimize
civilian casualties but one thing we
don't want to do you know everybody says
the use of human Shields the use of
civilians uh as a as a shield for
terrorists that's wrong okay but we have
to make sure that it's not merely
condemned we have to make sure that it's
ineffective and if the if the uh uh
blame is directed against Israel against
the victim that is returning fire with
the the most judicious use of military
power that's possible in these
circumstances if blame is placed on
Israel that that tactic becomes
effective and will be used again and
again and again and we can't allow that
in fact Kamas is saying they'll do it
again and again and again and that's why
we have to win out root them out
completely but also send a message to
the axis of terror you're not going to
win we're not going to let you do this
we defeated you here we'll defeat you
elsewhere and we should have the entire
civilized World line up behind behind
Israel while it's fight it fights this
battle of civilization it's our common
civilization against their common
barbarism civilization must win so
Israel Must Destroy Hamas to have peace
if you want peace destroy Hamas if you
want security destroy Kamas if you want
to beat the axis of Terror destroy Kamas
this is what Israel must do this is what
Israel is doing but it's not only doing
it for ourselves for our sake it's doing
it for your sake too for our common
future for the future a better future
for the for Israel for the Palestinians
for the Middle East for the world you
know when on one of my trips to Israel
and and I've been there a number of
times and I've interviewed you while in
Israel uh but on one of the trips where
there was a flare up uh that was when I
went into one of the terror tunnels I I
went it's almost 100t underground it's
it's sophisticated you know almost
architecture and it was all supposed to
be humanitarian aid for hospitals and
schools and infrastructure um but I also
stopped by a city a border city that you
know else they wrote and while there you
know prior to my arrival they had been
hit with 10,000 Rock rockets in 10 years
their children cannot play outside they
play in in Bunker
underground uh playgrounds in that in
that city um and that's the same with
many border cities and I I guess when we
get to the the real heart of this
doesn't all of this have to be rooted
out and and for example while the Iron
Dome has been enormously successful and
helpful and intercepted thousands of
missiles uh it can no long longer be a
launching pad I go back to that part but
also you talk about Hamas must be
destroyed what about Hezbollah do you
believe a victory over Hamas sends a
strong enough message that they stop
firing missiles from Lebanon into
Israel I think it's a necessary message
may not be sufficient but it's
definitely necessary because without
victory in the South you're certainly
not going to have deterence in the north
against balah and we'll have to deal
with that but I think the first step is
the first step and the first First Step
means uh Hamas did this Hamas is going
to pay for this uh and it's going to pay
for this by its total eradication by the
way you talk about underground tunnels I
mean they've got a network there of
hundreds of kilometers hundreds of miles
of underground tunnels that are used as
Terr tunnels as command posts command
bunkers uh and and you know what their
leader is like a little Hitler he's
sitting in the bunker and he's saying I
don't care about what happens to the
civilian population on top one of the
Kamas spokesman said the other day
you know the the tunnels the underground
is for us for the this Messianic violent
uh theological cult that has to be
destroyed and he said above ground
that's not our responsibility civilian
population that's Israel's
responsibility in the UN they don't care
a hoot about their civilian population
the only one that tries to keep them out
of Harm's Way is Israel we create safe
passages corridors we create a safe zone
for them and as we ask them to leave
guess who's trying to prevent them from
leaving the zone of fighting Hamas it's
not Israel that is f firing in the safe
Corridor given to
Palestinians it's Hamas it's not Israel
who's trying to keep these people at
gunpoint in the zone of fighting it's
Hamas so we're we're dealing here with a
brutal enemy that is committing a double
War crime of targeting our civilians and
hiding behind their civilians forcibly
uh keeping them in the zone of fighting
and I think all those people who are
naive and are you know who are either
naive or or misinformed or Worse who are
condemning Israel they should be Ian
they really should be ashamed of
themselves because they're aligning
themselves with pure sheer evil they
should support the forces of
civilization that are fighting this
barbarism because otherwise this
barbarism will spread hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get get it anywhere
else